what's up guys prestige here and today I
got some awesome minecraft Xbox news
about VN hence the PCN gameplay but here
we go picture all right now you check
this out this is the Enderdragon and in
the end in the Xbox minecraft edition so
that's awesome now to assess the picture
a little bit you got we got the
Enderdragon we got him recharging his
health at one of the crystals if you
don't know there are crystals around the
map that you have to destroy before you
attack the inner dragon and he um if you
just fight the Enderdragon overcharges
health in these crystals and you see in
the back there is a little up there
looks like there are iron bars around
one of the crystals now this is in pc
but here for jay was tweeting acid
gamers one guy asked acid acid dis
gamers acidic the city gamers asked so
why does this have why does this one
have iron bars around it anyone so 4j
Studios responded we are play testing
that we intended the last two spikes to
have an iron fence cage around the
crystal to stop lo quiera shots this
means we're going to have to ladder up
and fight and like break them which is
give me a lot harder than two narrow and
also something that's awesome you see
the inner dragon spraying something
that's ender acids guy named Kaz a asked
what it was and for Davis to do is read
it or responded sorry it's under acid
now this is awesome guys this means the
xbox is going to have multiple stuff
that the PC Edition doesn't have which
is crazy like you see here I'm blowing
crystal this means one of the crew the
crystals are gonna have cages around
them so you're gonna have to tunnel up
and by the way none of them for that
sure I don't know I got a lucky spawn
none of them are that small you're gonna
have to Don tunnel but build-up or
ladder up this is going to be insane
guys I'm so pumped for the Xbox to be
there making it unique even the pc which
is great they're having like different
stuff in tu9 there is some other stuff
into you know
and this since I'm just kind of starting
to work to cover this I haven't covered
that but i will be doing my best to
cover all of the updates and stuff for
you guys and when it comes out i will
definitely be showing you guys the end
for minecraft xbox so make sure you
subscribe if you aren't subscribed to
zero subscribers subscribe leave like at
this video if you enjoyed it that I
really appreciate it especially cuz its
new channel so my name is prestige I
really hope you all enjoyed p suckas